ça va le travail jean paul quand mason
erik thon c'est l'horreur et toi non
curiel pas même pas mal tu continues
tian bonjour ça va je suis bien content
de vous voir aujourd'hui dans l'île aux
enfants
c'est un temps formidable et moi
terminer mon dessin alors julie gelé une
temps quitté aujourd'hui qu'en me donne
mon un extraordinaire 20 et ben dis-donc
ça ça prend l'air d'aller aujourd'hui 1
si si si si ça va enfin julie je te
connais quand tu fais cette tête là
c'est que quelque chose tant nui à les
écouter
je suis pas si je peux parler devant
tout le monde comme ça enfin les amis
alors je me demande si on n'aurait pas
dû faire plus attention au programme qui
passe à la télévision dans notre
émission je fais très attention parce
que je veux dire
tu as vu les derniers temps là les
émissions sur la natation sur la
natation où ils formidable moi j'ai
trouvé passionnant qu'est ce que de
leurs proches rien monsieur inquiète
mais pourquoi c'est pas parce que ce
matin très tôt casimir est parti en me
disant qu'ils savent qu'ils avaient
appris à nager à la télévision et qu'il
allait se baigner et lamont à papier
dans les rochers tu sais je les mois je
crois que tu t'inquiètes pour rien
casimir n'est pas aussi qu un jeu il a
dû aller à la plage et puis tout
simplement trompé le bout de ses pieds
dans l'eau mais s'il croit que c'est
nager il va se noyer
menon mollo lui revient enfin ce qu'il
arrivait en criant c'est qui s'est pas
noyé
je suis complètement idiote répond
qu'avec ou des quads et des coûts des
cosmonautes des cours mais quand on l'a
peut-être fait des consignes et donc non
déco l'écho à des décors des cordes et
lesté par de chasse gardée qua non des
coucous pts et décrira les pirates
arrivent
casimir tu voulais dire des corsaires
oui oui les pirates font manger que du
mur du calme du calme
qu'est ce qui s'est passé est bien
j'étais tranquillement sur la plage en
train de me tremper les pieds lorsque
j'ai vu un énorme bateau de pirates dont
tu aurais pas un petit peu rêver oh non
non non c'était bien des pirates
les enfants rêveurs venez voir les
proches aidants prenez tout cela casimir
a besoin de nous voilà résumé il regarde
on a plein de silhouettes de navires ont
élu va voir si tu ne reconnais pas celui
que j'ai entendu oui tu me prends mon
crayon
qu'est ce que tu as elle s'était pas
celui-là regard casimir
c'est ce que je fais muriel là c'est un
bateau à roue les bateaux arous à
remonter les rivières avec une énorme
roula qui s'enfonçait dans l'eau et
notamment le mississippi
15 je lis tu me les prend et ce à un
cargo est pas un cargo non car oui
peut-être mais si c'est par bateau de
mythe et matra tu sais ce que c'est
qu'un cargo chantal c'est un bateau qui
transportent les marchandises et
quelquefois des passagers a alors là
c'était peut-être un pétrolier ont la
larme à métro il ya eu un gros comme ça
t'es pas et pétroliers n'ont qu'à
casimir les pétroliers modernes sont
très très très long et à l'arrière
l'habitation julie trappe
très beau bateau ça une loi c'est un
voilier à une goélette jolie et quelle
est la différence entre une goélette et
à voilier et un autre voilier est bien
c'est que le marc de l'avant est plus
petit que le mât de l'arrière du vin
l'avant est ici sur le dessin on
pourrait croire que c'est le contraire
mais l'avant et ici et ça ouhlala de
plus en plus beau qu'est ce que ces
sorts des émirs c'est parce que tu as vu
je ne sais pas si c'est alors le bateau
pirate non c'était encore plus gros ça
c'est un trois mâts du xviiie siècle
ouailles et des petits trous là c'était
pour faire passer les canaux encore un
autre c'est ça qui a vu un emploi c'est
pas ça ça c'était une galère égyptienne
voyez une toute petite voile tu serais
très très peu et là des galériens qui
ramène et ce à un drakkar normand c'est
parce que tu as non ça ressemblait pas
du tout à ça et ça ressemble à ce qu'on
vient de voir un à la galère si ce n'est
que là la voile est beaucoup plus grande
c'est avec ce bateau que les vikings ont
envahi la france en commençant par la
normandie
et ben voilà casimir endormi tous ses
bateaux est-ce qu'à celui que tu as vu
non non mais c'est pas celui que tu as
gardé la celui là ouais
oui c'est ça je le reconnais c'est le
bateau des pirates mais nous attendons
que j'ai mûri pendant cette période ça
une barque de mersch la 3ème du nom d'un
pointu pour aller la tête les yeux
regarde là bas voilà le t shirt à un
bonjour tout le monde
voilà la passion qu'on m'avait commandé
mademoiselle julie et je viens peut-être
j'ai dû passer par le port 1
il est parcours des souvenirs et la
pression de la mer oui je disais que
j'ai j'ai dû passer par le port parce
que au moment d'aborder sur la plage
j'ai vu un monstre attention mais pas
n'importe quel monstre un horrible
monstre et il se tremper les pieds dans
l'eau mois horribles
[Musique]